oh
[Music]
hi guys my name is joyce hi my name is
ayaka and we've been best friends for
about four years so our friendship is
pretty much surrounded by cooking we are
going to make two different kinds of
brownie so the first brownie that we're
going to make it's going to be very
simple only three ingredients that
sounds like something i could do yeah
for the second batch i believe it's the
fudgiest brownie
and you know i love some chocolate whoa
so excited
oh my gosh you were so precious okay so
let's look at the recipe all right
okay
okay we got that
that's like super easy okay you already
put in there
okay
i love a good three ingredients
wow
ah okay okay i i think i can do it oh
yeah i think i think this might be like
the brownie for me i think this is like
lazy girl sweat ah that looks good
though
since in our friendship ayaka does most
of the hard labor i'm gonna do all the
mixing okay so i'll take the control in
the video they put this one first yes
so i'm just gonna put them all
look at you
she cooking
so let me mix this first she's stirring
i'll mix for the next one
okay
my turn we have to put a like
right i mean we ain't no tasty producer
you expect me to what glaze this on into
the plate so now i'm gonna spread it
uh-huh i think i've done my job
successfully uh-huh let's bake it now
that the first batch is perfectly
cooking in the oven uh-huh let's watch
the second one all right cool
ever i really love butter love sugar
i just like how pretty this is it's just
so cinematic
it's more complicated for sure it's
definitely more comfortable yeah
i love chocolate chocolate girl
chocolate world it's a different process
okay it's it's complicated and then we
mix a different powder
oh my gosh yes more chocolate love it i
love this i need this
it's bread like my soul i love this
chocolate
yes i'm a little bit nervous really it's
just so much more pressure like look
cute tastes cute be cute the other one
just like accepted me for who i was but
this one wants me to be better you feel
me
[Music]
so i think we're excited let's start
this okay let's cook drop the butter all
right
mix with it mix with it i'm mixing i'm
mixing it with it
oh look at you drop that egg right
this is what teamwork looks like
it actually does smell good yeah i'm
surprised so she's pouring the melted
chocolate into our batter thingy
so now let's just get the sifter and mix
up all the dry ingredients so then we
just put this spoon
yes yes yes you could do this yeah sure
oh it's very loose it is very loose
compared to the first brownie the simple
gradients
it's very smooth but that looks like
chocolate yeah look me and that can be
sisters so as a final step we're gonna
put this beautiful chocolate chunk into
this chocolate chocolate brownie she
leaves all the powder all on the sides
you know what i'm saying all right so i
think we're good
now we're going to pour it in this
batter is good wow this is like really
creamy okay so i think the batter is
done let's put it in the oven and see
which one is the best
okay
look at our pretty children
okay so let's try the three ingredient
one first all right
this is good
oh good
over the ice cream oh hell yeah i like
this one though because it's not too
sweet yeah no
it's like basic
very simple yeah it's a very simple
style brownie so are you ready for the
next one yeah the bougie brownie yeah
bushy baby all right come on
man
dear friend yes
okay we have a meal
yeah
hell yeah
oh man that's good
just knowing for my lifestyle yeah i
would be eating this
okay
[Applause]
i have to be honest
i love this
i love it
[Music]
this is good
oh yes
[Music]
you